we are also developing like many other
still also machine learning models on
the state assembly okay so a few months
ago so I got this email from the
organizers of the platform for the UK
PowerPoint right so now like you
actually read the email but the key I
hope the key sentence is here so you
know you're a part of the study of the
cabal bank is your word so the
participants are actually free to was
follow their data from the kebab Bank at
any time right to say they're actually
able to make request didn't know long
would be used in in models and in this
particular moments right so there's some
participants I've decided that their day
national long we no longer use so this
is not an isolated incident right so you
know a few a little bit time after that
I got another email right so there's
another set of participants that won at
their data to be removable model okay so
so what does this mean so this means
that and so the models that I have
already trained on this data sets and
other people getting trained on this
data sets right so now we actually have
an obligation to take those data out
from the strained models I said I've got
a big neural network on this data set as
many people have and you figure out a
way to actually delete the inputs of
those individuals from that train neural
network
okay so I think this is a really
interesting example because it
illustrates a few key points I want to
discuss there's the first thing here is
that the data itself is actually
accessible and is actually free to
access there's any people in this group
that you can Nestle you know if you want
to work with data set you can actually
just apply for it and you'll be able to
access the data the second point is that
the data are the same data set is
actually being used to Train many
machine learning and statistical models
right both by companies like Google are
serviced by thousands of individual
research groups it's important to note
here that - the participants the
half-million people who participate in
the study actually gave their full
consent for the full data set to be
released right so they said okay let's
release the whole data set we start
adding nodes right so you know if you
are really want to attack the data right
because you have the G note
and you have all the lifestyle behavior
information I'm sure you could easily
identify the individuals but individual
given that knowledge said okay we still
give the consent
however the individuals are at any time
right can change their mind for any
reason right post privacy and non
privacy reasons to say I don't want my
data to be used anymore so take it out
from your models so the data is public
in a sense that if I want to do a study
on the data set I can request and
through a fairly simple process I have
access to data and work on the data sets
right so it's not something that anyone
can just can no Google and and download
so researchers very broadly defined
right so you can have Bob that company's
pharma companies that are all working on
the same data sets No so if I know so if
some researchers on the train there in
your network or train logistic question
they can't really release the four
weights of the neural network on the
github it's like I specified all like
what obligation you have to like then
like track down anyone who might have
released your I started might have used
your release models if you must do this
deletion procedure yes that's where it
gets hairy right so that's where it's
not clear how do we actually implement
these divisions both operationally I
mean how personally hard we delete data
from the machine learning algorithms
efficiently and also how do we ensure
that has been done yes there many so for
example I may not what my data to be
used for studies of genetic risks of you
know alcoholism rates not because I
don't want my data to be used in any
study just because I don't want my data
to be used for that kinds of studies
right so people give a lot of reasons
beyond privacy for why they there that
do not want to be used for particular
studies I'm going to give a concrete
mathematical definition of what the
usage is I just want to motivate the
problem first okay is the problem make
sense to people right so now you have
they does train down the model right so
now people have requests I have to
actually delete the data from that model
so once you've basically formulates what
will it formalize that into your
concrete problem so where does this fit
into the bigger landscape right so I
think the example of you could Bob back
illustrates a few interesting features
right since the theme of the workshops
on beyond privacy I think is how it's a
few other related questions right so
certainly security and privacy of data
is very important for these individuals
for example in the UK biobank for the
participants
right so they these are important but
even more important is basically this
notion of data governance rights so they
consented to have their data to be fully
released and be used in these studies
but they do want to have controls of
this data especially in a sense that
they can say I want my data to be
deleted from this model or from these
kind of studies at any time that they
want and I'll tell you why that's
actually a very different technical
question than privacy questions so so
basically for the the talk today I want
to highlight I mean I think there's been
a largely a lot more work technical work
on the privacy area but actually very
little work about deletion and more
broadly about data governance so I want
to give you a flavor of what are the
technical questions involved and how do
we formulate these problems for the
computer science audience yes
yes so there's also a lot of discussions
about like who actually owns the data
right so he needs the case of the UK
Bell Bank right so it's not that's where
the participants participate in the
study the data is not owned by the by
the UK government or by the study
organizers right so because if that's
the case then they're the ones who can
decide who has access to the data who
can use the data or not right so the
users the participants still have some
control over who actually can access and
use the data because they can't decide
if I want to delete the data or not so
so data deletion I think it's actually
really fundamental and fundamental
components to this problem of data
governance right so many of you also
heard about the right for data
you don't write to be forgotten from the
GDP our regulation right you can which
says that so also individuals can have
certain rights in particular rights
where they want to say that their
individual personal data are to be
erased right and no longer processed
right so I think that's also very much
related to the question that we saw with
the UK biobank may ever have to make two
remarks on the GDP our so in the consent
article of the GPR it says very
explicitly that if you withdraw your
consent the consent remains valid for
the period that you had given it my
impression is that that means that you
could never ask that your data is
removed from the model you could
probably only looking at article 7 say I
don't want my data to be shared anymore
there's something else in the GDP are
there is a very very large research
exception it's exceptionally large and
basically says that once data is used
for scientific research
and that is a game very broad can also
be the private sector it is assumed that
the purpose is okay and you could have
as a legal ground legitimate interest of
the data control alert so as far as
Europe is concerned I think this would
not be an issue so let me I so that's a
great comment I want to if there's time
I'll follow up that at the very end I
also just want to say that the case of
the equilibar Bank is actually quite
different from what you said right so
there are the explicit obligations that
the data once the data is be removed
right if someone has trained a
prediction or diagnosis algorithm that's
using the data right there's some
obligation that she remove the data from
the Train but GDP I think there's also
discussion and a debates about how
exactly to interpret that switch I'll
follow up later on so okay so so that's
the motivation that's how we actually
started on this problem so here are the
sort of technical considerations right
so as you know as many machine learning
models especially the more modern
machine learning models are actually
quite good at remembering data right
they're also traces of the information
from the data sets especially training
data encoded in the algorithm the
obligation is to be seen from the email
that I got right from the UK biobank
actually asked for exactly sure
right so no so we actually won't really
want to have some notion that we have
exactly removed the individual from the
models the deletion can't connect
request cannot create an online fashion
that can happen any time right I know of
these Cerf I think make the problem
quite interesting and difficult from a
technical perspective right so what I
want to do here and what the goal of our
research agenda is to first move on to
formulate this problem which to our
knowledge has really not been done
before and then I'll tell you about some
preliminary results that we have but
it's very much I think open for
interpretation
yes so I'm just wondering are you gonna
compare to just relearning on those yes
I'll talk about that too yeah okay so
I'll go to the board and then show you
the formulations of the problem and then
I'll come back and show you some
experimental results we have
just in case there there's still people
who we need it okay so the
okay so the setup the problem right so
Steve here's how we want to formulate
the problem right so you're given a
public data set you have a data set
your data sets and you have some
learning algorithm right so your
learning algorithms think of it as some
algorithm right that takes your data
sets into into a model the model could
be set of a regression model it could be
unsupervised learning so I could be
posed to provide supervised all right so
think of this model what as corresponds
to your you know coming from some
particular model class so just an
example right so if your model is just
running in linear regression all right
so you take your data you could run
either new question and you get the
parameters the weights of you're doing
the question or it could be the weight
of your neural network okay so it's a
very simple generic model right so
here's how we want to define deletion
so given I have some data set and then
my algorithm okay so what we want to say
is that's okay so and I want to delete
the life point from this data set right
make sure I get this notation right
right the eye is a mapping
status
from my data sets my current algorithm
this point I into a new model so this is
just this is very general way to say
that okay so a division operation is
just take us input my training data set
the model that I already have and the
point I want to remove and just pissing
me back out like a new learning
algorithm right and you classifier a new
regression model yeah so this is the
particular that learned the model like
the weights of my network okay so it's a
mapping and such that
so that's the the model that I returned
here after my deletion operation should
be the same as the model I trained if I
never had this data point in the first
place so if my learning algorithm is
like a share randomized algorithm which
could be the case right then I would
like this to be true sort of in
distribution but for simplicity just
think of it as a deterministic learning
algorithm I must get the same algorithm
back after I do my deletion operation
when I read your abstract that you know
I'll actually flush this back up again
so actually we can consider both
scenarios right so here the actual email
this email says that's this entire
individuals data needs to be removed
from from anything right so all of the
features need to be removed so we can
also consider I guess subsets we can
consider both scenarios right but that's
for now just focus on for simplicity's
to focus on this case where I remove an
individual very used to me that the
algorithm a is
because it's not sure what it means what
a of d-sub - i means when all I've told
you is what behavior a take on D right
so yes so I'll show you so you can have
different algorithms for learning this
alright so I'll show you some examples
but all that's for the division to make
sense so that it says that is no doesn't
matter how you reach this algorithm
right the end result has to be the same
as if I've never seen this data point in
the first place I guess I mean for an
outside observer what does it mean for
the algorithms being able to be the same
as what it would have been an outside
observer who doesn't have access to the
algorithm doesn't know so is there some
accuracy can some notion of accuracy of
the algorithm in your well so there
should be the same in terms of the if
you think that that it's the parameters
of the algorithm should be exactly the
same right so if you have a
deterministic algorithm right aleem
every question this similarity these
should be indistinguishable even to an
observer who knows a complete
description of it let me actually push
out a little bit more in the interest of
time and then I'll take more questions
after
okay so that's the deletion operation
right so so that's just a definition I
haven't told you anything yet right
so the point here is that so I want to
make a couple of remarks right so first
is that deletion is top of data deletion
it's really a computational problem and
in contrast I would say most of the
question from privacy is more
statistical so what does this mean so
this means that so here I'm purely
interested in efficient addition
algorithms right so any algorithm I can
achieve this deletion operation by
simply retraining from scratch and it's
what suppose say so I can switch mean
Alton's from scratch so clearly in most
cases for new and networks in particular
that's actually not really not feasible
right so the outputs and question is how
to actually achieve this efficiently
given in any learned model right so
where's the privacy questions I think is
quite worth okno right so you can have
algorithms that are differentially
private that do not support the
efficient additions and also vice versa
so I want to give a couple of examples
of yes well differentially private alwa
somes do not support exact data vision
wait so then we can get into arguments
about is that sufficient but certainly
not by the letter of the of this request
emails so I want to show you what are
some examples the algorithms that are
efficiently deletable and what are the
ingredients of how we can build up such
algorithms can I actually just push out
a bit so first example is actually uh
let's just look at lead every question
as a warm upper case so have y equals 2x
listen epsilon right so here my model
that learning output somehow figure out
beta you can do whatever your favorite
ways to do it right so so the standard
way to
okay so so if I want to delete an
individualized individual at data point
from this data set right so the idea is
how can we actually compute weight up
the new beta hat with the item visual
delete it as quickly as possible right
we still have to resolve this least
square problem so it turns out that for
in this case actually deletion is
relatively easy
right so if I wanted to leave eighth
point I can actually directly to
subtract it from here the harder part is
how do we actually do this through this
in to this part right and this I can
actually also turns out to basic remove
individuals and delete them in time of
basically P squared so there's no
dependence on n which is crucial here so
n is the number of individuals I have I
said we want ideally deletion algorithms
that are independent of the size of my
data set here you see what you store is
both expose yes not changing it really
but you're saying you have to store
extra we can store extra but the goal
here is that joint deletion time have
something that's independent of N and
that's really the sort of algorithm it
goes I want to find out assumes where I
can delete in time this is independent
of n but will be with some dependence on
the dimensionality of the problem
so the other kinds of problems right
that you've seen already there where you
can have explicit efficient deletion are
basically things like nearest neighbor
kind of algorithms right so cleaners
neighbors if I actually remove off the
nearest neighbors from a training
dataset I can actually just basically
forget about them so that basically the
ingredients that we were coming up with
for efficient data division or
algorithms that have this property are
the follows oh it's one more example
it's very quickly so it turns out that
flashy for gradient descent based
algorithms right they're actually not
efficiently deletable right so the idea
there is that if you know you have you
take some gradient descent or even SGD
right so if want the particular
gradients depends on a particle data
points then that information can
propagate it's actually very hard to
unwind these data points even for even
if the problem is convex I said we have
lower bounds to show that so you can't
really do that so what are things that
are you know easy to work with all right
so basically if you have useful summary
statistics so in the linear regression
case you have useful summary statistics
if you have sort of nonparametric or in
some sense local algorithms ok nearest
neighbor were sort of kernel regression
type methods on nonparametric if you
have some hierarchical models but I say
thump ow you have models that are using
data sets in a hierarchical manner right
I'll show you an example of that if
there's time then you can delete things
and then in the last part maybe the most
interesting parts there are algorithms
where it can efficiently check
if an exactly she would actually I
changed the outcome or not if deletion
matters so if you can do this then we
can actually do this officially so in
the last remaining two minutes Archie
should show you maybe at the high level
what we could do right now and what are
the experimental results right so so
basically the I want to just illustrate
this for in the case of unsupervised
learning so clustering problems right so
in clustering this even we'll just look
at the simplest version so k-means it's
a bunch of individuals i want to crush
them into K groups I said even there
will have to be a bit careful how to
design algorithms as are actually
exactly deletable so there are basically
two types of algorithms like I wanted to
talk about to illustrates the
hierarchical notion and then the last
notion of officially checkable all right
so the idea of hierarchy for clustering
is that if I basically split my datasets
into different groups right if you
imagine randomly linked data points into
these groups and then if within each
group computes know some local k-means
right past those clusters up in some
hierarchical notion then if I have to
delete a particular data point then I
only have to change this basically this
particular path right so the time
basically somehow logarithmic rather
than linear in the number of data points
and then very quickly for the efficient
checkable version of high purple cluster
of clustering is that basically look at
quantized
nice clustering where the idea there
such that it's an algorithm that we
developed where the idea there is that
instead of looking at assigning exact K
means that every iteration right every
every step every iteration of k-means
that's actually essentially quantized
the centroids and then keep track of
where the centroids are quantized to
really keep track of history of that
that which enables us to efficiently
check in real time if the data point
comes long did that actually change any
of the trajectories of centroids
so basically experimentally you're just
showing various deletion experiments on
a couple of real data sets whereas if we
actually just run real standard
algorithms right versus running these
quantized or hardcore algorithms in here
she gets like four orders of magnitude
improvements in the amortize deletion
times right so if you actually really
want to run these kind of algorithms in
a large data sets while still committing
to the the notion that you can give
people governance and deleting their
data when they request it and I think we
need to investigate more in these
efficiently deliver algorithms I'll stop
here we'll come back to these earlier
questions about why this problem to
solve in a technical level have you
looked at the literature and history
independent data structures connection I
have I've lifted my voice we have seen
some things are those lines but maybe
it's worth discussing more offline of I
were looking at the same literature odds
in the context of sort of some
cryptographic context yeah not not
machine learning models yeah different
kinds of data structures okay same
tricks probably the other question I had
was about so you're okay with linear
time linear space you just want the time
updates to be like the running time of
the updates to be fast
that's that correct and does it matter
if the size of your data structure and
the complexity of stated making
decisions were to increase as you delete
more and more points or increase slowly
Bradley is yeah he ultimately would spot
practical algorithms right look at the
current standards clustering algorithms
and your networks are just they're not
practical for feeding data points right
so whatever is practical if I have a
reasonable space reasonable memory I'm a
reasonable complexity I'm happy with
those practical solutions why can't that
also with two things like one is um like
if we think of it as being like a
disclose model it's kind of like yeah
okay you can imagine trying to make some
change here like if we had like I signed
up to find the anus which is based on
like the data that people disclosed like
what does it mean sort of like on you
the publication of that scientific
finding and I wonder if like that is
even relevant here and then they sort of
the question is the extend um can think
of differential privacy as sort of
saying it like it doesn't really kind of
matter whether or not you're in the
dataset like and I know I'm I can't
believe in here but like if that's how
we understand it what does it also mean
to say that someone really should have
like a right to withdraw their data if
the guaranteed to provide internal
policies like it doesn't matter that
they're in the dataset yes I think these
are all great questions right so it's
actually very early stages of discussion
for any of these questions right so the
the point that we want to take is that's
the current commitment that our offer
requests required of researchers to
delete in the base data right it's this
the exact solution it's actually not
practical it's not feasible given our
current algorithms
right so even for that limited problem
all right so I think we already need to
think about how to formulate the problem
and how to come up with better
algorithms and then as you write then
there's the higher-level questions about
when is this actually going to achieve
the desired outcomes as so I agree that
force is excited findings if you find
that this power markers relate to breast
cancer
you can't retract that paper maybe if
people decide to withdraw their data but
if you have a predictive model that's
taking information from the 23andme and
predicts you know height or disease
risks right now some subset of
individuals in 23andme on to withdraw
their data you can imagine actually
changing that predictive model after the
models develop you're continuing that
the model is still using yes yeah I'm
not sure the data protection law with
you is that way I think this part of
what well from a machine learning
perspective right so the model is
certainly actually using the data for
example if I have a K nearest neighbor
algorithm
I mean it's explicitly using the data
that the neural network is some alpha
skating holiday that's being used so we
have a particular definition of that
year discussion question so let's say
it's a positive and then it's a question
of whether you really remove this person
or not because of the choice of other
people